Oh
I think that the primary well there's
some preconditions to be good at it you
have to be able to subordinate your own
ego it's not your book it's the writers
book you have to help be willing to let
help the writer do what the writer was
just to accomplish and not what you
would like the writer to accomplish
that's number one number two is a
general sense of empathy I guess that's
a similar to what I just said
understanding what the writer is trying
to do and three in my case frankness I
mean it doesn't do me any good to hear
an auditor say oh it's great it's great
it's great I really wanted that are
going to say I didn't understand this or
that sentence is awful or this stuff
doesn't belong here belongs there now I
won't always be persuaded but i want the
by editor to make that case as firmly
and as supportively as possible and
supportively means not telling me I'm
good but telling me this is how to be
better
I think the best advice I've ever had as
a writer was hope in your that your
research disproves your preconceptions
and push further said that you can get
there now it doesn't always happen but
we all begin on a subject having an idea
of where we're going and the most
satisfying work that I've always done is
when I start going this direction and
then I find oh no no no go back this
direction I know writers who have
completed books and nearly completed
books and I realized oh my god I've got
it all wrong Jean Strauss the wonderful
biographer her JP Morgan book took I
don't know 14 or 15 years because she
was nearly done when she realized she
really hadn't gotten Morgan right and
she went back and did it all over again
the willingness to be wrong and to
recognize that as absolutely essential
the other great advice is a this is a an
aphorism that has been attributed to
Hemingway to PG Woodhouse to I don't
know every writer of note in the 20th
century you have to be willing to kill
all your little darlings by which I mean
or whoever said that meant you know you
write a sentence that you think is so
clever and so perfect and what has such
great rhythm to it and what a great joke
it is and you fall in love with the
sentence for its own sake rather than
for what it's meant to convey that's a
little darlings you have to be able to
go oh and just get rid of it
I think that I would still get into
journalism if I had the opportunity to
but you know again I'd rather play
center field or I'd rather be the leader
of a 16-piece swing band but I'm not
capable of those things so assuming that
i had the same set of skills that i
indeed do have I think that journalism I
mean I've had a wonderful time doing it
it's I have never had a boring day in my
career and I think that most journalists
will tell you that I let me take that
back my first job as a reporter I
covered sewer bored suburban Detroit all
you know that's not fun but once I was
established as a professional never
never a boring day so I would like to do
that now if I were coming up now I'd be
looking at all there are no jobs the
journalism business is falling apart and
I would hope that I would have the
willingness to live in the cold water
flat or whatever I would need to do to
get established I do think these other
forms I've spoken about I think that
they will evolve they may not be here
yet I think that the major institutions
like the times will survive and thrive
in somewhat different form and I think
that there will always be an audience
for books I don't think we'll have the
physical entity necessarily but the idea
of writing as I did in this case 155,000
words on the subject and selling it to
people who are interested in reading it
that'll still be here and so I would
feel easy for me to say at 62 but if I
were 22 I would want to do the same
thing for a living